[MUSIC PLAYING]
MORGAN HALLMON: So first of all,
thank you, everyone, for one,
finding this--
a little difficult to get
here from the main area--
and two, for coming
at the end of the day.
I realize that I am the
last thing between you
and starting your
evening, so I really
appreciate you're
making it here.
So GCP Next day one.
A lot of exciting stuff
was announced today,
and I hope you're excited to
hear about a few more things,
and the cool things that you
can build on top of Google Cloud
platform.
So with that, I'm
going to jump into it.
So as I said, I know
it's the end of the day.
I'm going to promise
to keep it light, fun.
There's actually even
a demo at the end
with a little bit of
audience participation
so please stay for that,
and let's get started.
So my name is Morgan Hallmon.
I'm a product manager on the
Serverless team within GCP,
and I can't wait to tell
you about what you can build
using Serverless and Events.
And so I thanked you a number
of times-- one for finding it,
two for coming at
the end of your day--
and three, for attending
a session that actually
had a pretty nebulous title.
Right?
Doing More with Less.
With less what?
Well, here at
Google, we care a lot
about developer productivity.
We really want you
to be able to do
the most in the
shortest amount of time
and add value to your users.
So we want you to
be able to code
with less code, less
infrastructure, and less work
overall.
And I'm going to talk to
you about Serverless Events
and how we make that possible.
And so what would be your ideal?
If you had any
system, any framework,
what would be your
ideal framework?
It would be one that
allows you to do nothing
but focus on your business
logic, to focus on user value,
the things that keep users
coming back to your application
day in and day out, which
is frankly hard enough.
And things such as
monitoring, configuration,
service discovery,
auto healing, rollback,
all these complicated
and thankless tasks that,
frankly, at times
take teams of people
to do-- they're very,
very important--
but they have almost
nothing to do with actually
running your business.
So ideally, you would just
focus on business logic.
And software has evolved
for this purpose.
Right?
If you remember the old
days of httpd and Apache,
you had this very,
very thin interface
that literally just lets
you receive a request
and send a response, and
everything in between you
had to do yourself.
And over time, software
evolved to do you
a lot more of the
heavy lifting for you.
A lot of the modern frameworks
do just about everything
nowadays.
They do routing, and they
do session management.
They do caching, ORM
so you don't actually
have to talk to the database.
A lot of the heavy
lifting has been
removed when it comes
to writing software,
and infrastructure has been on
this same trend of evolution,
abstracting away
more and more, such
that you can focus more
on adding user value,
focus more on business logic.
From the early days of
self-hosted servers--
I mean, if you've been in
the industry for a while,
maybe you remember
the days where
you had a coworker or
colleague running a $10 million
business under their desk.
Right?
I mean, it was kind of the wild
wild west, but certainly not
the way to build a resilient,
a reliable, a fault tolerant
business.
And we then moved to
managed data centers.
We then moved to colos.
We got more efficiency.
We moved to VMs where you'd pack
more onto the machine itself.
And then public cloud was
a step function change,
making it much, much easier
to provision infrastructure,
much, much easier
to build systems.
And then even on
top of public cloud,
we've added a lot of services
to make things even easier
on you as a developer,
things like App Engine, Big
Query, Cloud Storage, Compute
Engine, Data Store, Firebase,
Data Flow, and many
other technologies.
But there's still a
lot of challenges.
I mean, it's not it's not a
completely solved problem.
There's complexity.
Even a modest internet
business these days--
let's say you're
doing e-commerce.
A small e-commerce site, you've
probably got a users database,
a products database, a
transactions database.
You're getting a number
of different APIs.
It's necessarily complex.
You've got inefficient
infrastructure, many of you,
in that, if you're running on
traditional infrastructure--
let's say you have nothing
more than a diurnal pattern
to your usage.
Let's say you're in a single
geography, single continent.
When your users are asleep
and not actually hitting
your service, you're
still running servers.
You're inefficient, and then
these systems, at times,
can be very difficult to extend.
It's the corollary of
the complexity point
that the more
complex the system,
every new feature
you want to add
ends up being surgery
that you do that system.
And so you know it's
called Doing More
With Less, Serverless
and Events,
so know I'm going to say that
Serveless plus Events helps
you solve these problems.
So how does it do it?
So one, it's very
simple, and I'm
going to talk more about
each one of these points.
It's just code.
You give us your code.
We do everything else.
It's fully managed.
Again, we run your code.
We take care of patching,
and auto scaling,
and everything else.
You just give us your
actual business logic,
and we do everything else.
And we automatically make
connections between services,
so you don't need to think
about APIs, and handshakes,
and all that.
It's efficient in that
you pay for what you use.
Again, in that diurnal
example, with Serverless,
when you're users are
asleep, you're not paying.
It's event driven.
So again, we only spin up
compute when there's actually
an event to process.
And then finally,
it's extensible,
so the very nature of Serverless
encourages us to write software
as microservices.
And so adding a new feature,
adding new functionality,
is as simple as just
adding a new microservice
to your overall application.
And so now let's
talk really briefly
about Google's Serverless
event-driven framework
Cloud Functions.
And yes, I'm calling
it a framework in that,
very much like the web
and app frameworks,
Cloud Functions is
a framework that
sits on top of Google's
infrastructure, that lets you
very simply access a number
of services and just focus
on writing your code.
And so it's Serverless.
What does that mean?
No server management.
You don't even need to
think about servers.
Simple deployment model.
Just give us your code.
I can't say that enough times.
We auto-scale it up and
down, and you pay only
for what you use.
It's even driven.
Seems pretty simple, but
let me just go through it.
An event is admitted.
If your function is
configured to listen
to that particular event,
we then spin it up.
Your code executes.
And so what does this look like?
This looks like just focusing
on your business logic.
We had all those
things that needed
to happen to actually
get your code in a place
where it could spin
up and run and respond
to things on that
very first slide,
or I guess that second slide.
But this is where your focused,
just your business logic now.
And Cloud Function supports
events for more than 20 Google
services.
So many of the most
popular Google services
are already integrated
with Cloud Functions,
and we're adding
more all the time.
And this is really
exciting for us
because each new
source that we add
ends up unlocking a whole
new set of use cases.
And you can imagine that the
things you can build with,
let's say, a Cloud
build integration,
or a Stackdriver
Logging integration
are quite different from
the things you might
build with a Gmail integration.
And so every time we open
up one of these new sources,
developers just amaze us and wow
us with the things they build.
Frankly, you guys are much
more creative than we are.
And so a recap.
Why should you do it
this way, this Serverless
and even driven way?
Again, it's simple,
it's efficient,
and it's extensible,
easily accessible.
So don't just take
my word for it.
That's enough of the theory.
Let's look at an actual example.
So in the traditional
development model,
I'm going to go to a situation
or scenario that many of you
have probably faced.
If you've done anything
consumer facing at least,
you've probably
faced a situation
where you want to
allow people to create
profiles or some
sort of artifact
that they exist in your system.
And so if you've got
profiles, you probably
want to have a photo
associated with that profile.
So the user, let's say,
want's to upload a photo,
and then you want to
crop it and store it down
for the profile's page.
How would you do that in
the traditional model?
Well, you probably
stand up a server
and use a single server
rout to do everything.
And so the user would
upload the photo,
the route would crop the
image and store it down
into the profile's directory.
That's not too bad.
But now I want to extend that.
I want to resize
that same image,
and I want to use it
for my user gallery.
Right?
I've got a number of
images, let's say.
I want to be able
actually have a gallery
and see all the
users that are there.
How would we do that?
Well, we just add more
logic to our server router.
So now we upload the photo.
We crop the image.
We store it into
storage and profiles.
We now resize the photo.
We stored into the
gallery section.
That was a fair amount of
work, but at least we're done.
But now, let's say I want
to index those profile
images for searches.
Let's say some meta data comes
in, and it's the user's name.
You should do a search
via name for some profile
that's on the system.
So what do I do?
Well, let's just add even more
logic to that server route.
So upload the image, crop
it, stored in profiles,
resize the image,
store it in a gallery,
and now take that
metadata-- in this case,
I've shown the first name,
last name, and the image URL--
and let's write
that into search.
Is anyone starting to feel
a little bit like this woman
at the edge of this cliff?
Very cool picture.
I don't know how they took it.
It looks like she's
going to fall.
But what's wrong
with this model?
Right?
What are some of
the shortcomings.
Well, it's incredibly complex.
There's a lot going on
inside that single route.
It's hard to understand
because so much is going on.
It's hard to debug.
The infrastructure
is inefficient.
We have a server in the middle
to do nothing but just write
things to storage.
It doesn't need to be there.
We have servers running
whether there's traffic or not.
And then it's
difficult to extend.
Every change requires
surgery to route
because we keep
adding more and more,
and I have even talked about
some of the hairy distributed
systems problems
associated with failures.
What happens?
You know, how do
we handle retries?
And so is there
another way to do this?
Again, the title is
Serverless+Events.
You know I'm going to
go to Serverless Events.
So yes, there's another
way, but let's look
at how the Event-driven model
helps to solve this problem.
So how would we do this
with Cloud Functions,
Google's event-driven,
Serverless framework?
Well, let's say a
user would then upload
the file direct to storage.
WE don't need a server.
There are no servers in
this picture whatsoever.
That would then cause
an event to fire.
This is called object.finalize.
The name is unimportant, but
it's basically a create event.
That then causes a function to
trigger, which crops the image
and stores it down
into profiles.
No servers on this page.
Nothing for you as a
developer to operate,
less code, less
infrastructure, less work.
With Cloud Functions, we
really can do more with less.
And so let's come back to
some of those advantages
that I talked about on
that slide with the more
simple, efficient, extensible.
Let's start with simple.
So there's less
boilerplate code to write.
And then even in the
very, very lightweight web
serving framework, like
Flask here in Python,
there's a lot of boilerplate.
I've got to import Flask.
I've got to decorate
my route to tell it
where to send the request.
I've got write a main function
to actually run the app.
There's just a lot
here that has nothing
to do with the business logic.
The business logic is really
just in two lines of code here.
And for those of you who
actually know something
about deployment, if you're not
just writing the back end code,
but potentially
deploying it as well,
you know I've skipped
an entire step, which
is having to configure NGINX.
How do I configuring my proxy?
Who here believes that the
way they add superior value
to their users is by
configuring NGINX better
than the competition?
It's somewhat rhetorical.
Please, no one raise their hand.
But it's true, right?
It's something we all
have to deal with,
and it adds almost
no user value.
And to be clear, so you don't
feel like I'm beating up
on NGINX, I think it's great.
It's wonderful.
In fact, we, here
at Google, package
NGINX into many of our
images for our run times.
But again, it's something
we should worry about,
not something that you as a
developer should worry about.
You should just worry
about your code.
And let's look at
what happens when
we start doing this in
the Serverless Events way.
It's just the business logic,
just those two lines of code.
Google is your framework.
Google is your proxy.
It's also simple in the sense
that it's single purpose.
So we go from
something like this--
and I know I've kind of loaded
this slide by calling it
the monolith handler--
but we go from a
handler that's doing
a lot of different things.
It's cropping an image.
It's saving it to storage.
It's resizing the image,
saving it to storage.
It's indexing the metadata.
And again, I didn't even talk
about retries and failures.
I showed a pretty simple case.
We move from that to this, where
everything is single purpose.
We're still doing all
same steps, admittedly.
We still have to resize it.
You have to crop it.
You have to index things.
But everything is
single purpose,
and it's much easier
to understand,
much easier to debug.
And oh, you know those
distributed systems problems
associated with
failures and retries,
you know who handles that?
Google.
We retry your code
when it fails.
And it's also
simple in the sense
that we make automatic
connections between services.
And so this is a point
that at times can get lost.
But if I want to talk from
service A to service B--
let's say it's Cloud Storage
talking to a Cloud Function--
I don't have to pull.
I don't have to check to
say, did something change?
Is something new?
When most of the time,
the answer is, no.
The event is delivered directly
to my Serverless function.
There are no APIs to contact.
I don't need to figure out
how to go talk to the service
to go get a piece of data.
I don't need to know how to go
talk to a service to configure
it to talk to my function.
All the data that
I need is delivered
to my event, delivered directly
to my function in most cases.
And then finally, we broker
those connections automatically
in the sense that it literally
takes about five seconds
in the UI, maybe two seconds
in the command line, to say,
wire function x up to
Cloud storage bucket B,
making it very,
very simple for you
to build sophisticated
and powerful systems.
It's also very efficient.
I won't belabor
this point because I
think you've heard it
many times, but if you
have an input that looks
like this, something that's
kind of spiky.
Let's say you're
a startup company,
and you have very few
users adding profiles
in the very beginning of
your company's evolution.
Or maybe you're very
mature, and people already
have the profiles
on their system.
And let's pretend that
this is not Facebook
where people change their
profile every single day,
but a normal website where you
might change it once a year.
Your input could very
well look like this.
With Cloud Functions, your
bill would track the input.
With the traditional
server dominated model,
when that server's up,
you're paying for it.
And then it's also
very extensible.
So let's go back to
that original example.
We were already bursting at
the seams with complexity
when we just had three steps.
Now let's say I want
to add a fourth.
Let's say I want to actually
extract information out
of the image.
I don't want to just take the
metadata that you've provided.
I want to see what's
going on in the image.
Maybe I want to make
it a visual search,
and then I want to
index those attributes
for even better searches.
So how could I do this?
Well, I could just add
more logic to the server.
I could upload the photo, crop
it and save it, resize and save
it, index the metadata, run
it through the Vision API,
and analyze the information
and index those tags.
But that's a lot of work.
That's a lot of surgery
that we have to go do.
Whereas with the Serverless
model, the Event-driven model,
let's say I saved
the original image,
and I'm triggering these
three function flows--
the crop and save, the resize
and save, the index metadata--
I've already got this.
Adding a new piece
of functionality
is as simple as just adding
another action to the upload
event--
much, much simpler and
much more extensible,
no surgery required.
And so a recap--
it's simple; it's just
code; it's fully managed;
we automate all the connections.
It's efficient.
You pay for what you use,
and it's Event-driven.
Then finally, it's
highly extensible,
in that you're basically
writing microservices,
so extending it is as simple
as adding a new microservice.
So don't take my word for it.
Let's look at how some customers
are using Serverless+Events
to build very
sophisticated systems.
So the first customer
we're going to talk about
is Smart Parking, and they're
building a realtime analytics
system.
Little bit of information
on Smart Parking.
So they've been
around for 15 years.
They're in Australia,
New Zealand, and the UK.
They've got Tens of thousands
of sensors in production,
and they are powered by
Google Cloud platform.
Let's hear a little bit
more about what they do.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: The
number of cars using
urban roads is on the rise,
putting additional strain
on traffic infrastructure.
Finding a safe and convenient
place to park your car also
adds to the frustration
of planning a journey.
We have a solution for this
in our Smart Park system.
The beauty of Smart Park lies
in its simplicity and agility,
allowing us to
configure each site
to any sets of requirements.
First, we survey and assess
which of our technologies
is most suitable to
record vehicle activity.
This could be both automatic
number plate recognition,
variable message signs, car
counters, in ground or overhead
sensors, or a mix
of all of the above.
These sensing
devices are designed
to relay live parking events
to our Smart Spot units, which
provide gateways
for the data and act
as zones of compatibility
for other services.
Let me introduce you to the
brains behind our system.
We call it Smart Cloud, and
it's a powerful and intuitive
two-way communication
platform that processes
millions of events each day.
First, Smart Cloud
intakes the data
from the Smart Spot gateways.
It then processes each action
and sends realtime information
around guidance and
availability to display
such as our mobile app,
overhead occupancy indicators,
and guidance signage.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MORGAN HALLMON: So
I know a lot of you
came in from different locales,
but if your city looks anything
like San Francisco, I
know you're probably
asking one question
after seeing that video.
When is this coming to my city?
Very, very interesting solution.
They're doing some
wonderful things.
So what are some
of the challenges
associated with building a
realtime data analytics system?
Well, one, you need up to
the minute, sometimes even up
to the second, freshness.
You could imagine that
having stale data, if you're
the operator of a parking
lot or parking garage,
can be a huge problem.
If there's an event
going on, such as a ball
game or a concert, being stale
by even as much as 10 minutes
could show a very,
very different picture.
Two, the data's coming from
a disparate set of sources.
So you saw in the video,
they've got in-ground sensors.
They've got overhead sensors.
They've got plate readers.
They've got car counters,
many different sensors,
providing data into this system.
And so as a result,
what do you have to do?
You've got to
normalize that data,
you've got to
transform that data,
and then finally you've got to
aggregate it, so a lot of data
manipulation that Smart
Parking has to do.
And how are they doing it?
Well, with this
architecture here.
So this is their Smart
Cloud architecture,
and you can see they
have a number of devices
that are sending information
from the different parking
spots.
They've got their
Smart Spots, which
do a little bit of aggregation
of just the raw data,
and then the backbone
of this system
is really Google IoT Core.
It's taking in all the
data and piping that
into GCP through
Pub/Sub, at which point
it then enters two
different data flows.
So one is the event flow,
where the raw data is simply
being piped in and saved
into persistent storage.
And if you notice, this
whole thing is Serverless.
There's no infrastructure
to operate.
And then there's the data flow.
And it's almost inap--
I shouldn't say inappropriately
named, but poorly named
or unfortunately
named because we
have a product called Data Flow
that sits in the data flow.
But try not to be confused.
Bottom line, what
it's doing there
is it's running through a number
of different analytics systems,
so BigQuery, Cloud ML, Datalab--
sorry, Vision Datalab
Cloud ML, and it's
analyzing the data, adding
insights to the data,
and then also saving it
into persistent storage.
At that point, there are
APIs that digest the data
and send that data
to different clients.
You've got dashboards, so this
is the parking garage operator.
They can see in realtime
what's going on.
Payments-- so if you're
making a payment,
keeping that data accurate.
Signage, so you know how many
spots are available or free
in a particular area.
Our favorite, enforcement here.
Yes, they are helping
folks when you
have overstayed your welcome
in a particular parking spot.
And then finally, there's
a metrics pipeline
for folks internal
in the company
to understand how the
network is performing
and perhaps even
troubleshoot some issues.
So all of this is done without
operating any infrastructure.
And don't take my word for it.
Listen to their CTO.
In fact he's here at GCP Next.
You'll recognize him from that
wonderful beard that he's got.
If you see him,
tell him I said, hi.
But just listen to the
efficiency and the productivity
that he has gotten out
of operating a Serverless
Even-driven infrastructure.
They were able to
completely re-architect
their platform, something that
took them 12 years to build,
in less than 18 months
using Serverless.
That allowed them to then
expand their business globally.
Also Cloud Functions, our
Serverless Even-driven
framework, was the foundation
for their Smart Cloud data
intelligence platform, and
it provides their customers
with instant to-the-second
accurate data intelligence
and scale for millions
of transactions each day.
So a very sophisticated, very
powerful system operating
absolutely no infrastructure.
So let's switch
gears a little bit--
this is the last
customer example I have--
but to something that's
completely different,
to building a
mobile application.
So I want to tell you about
how development firm POSSE
used Serverless and Events
to build the Hamilton App.
Let's hear a little
bit more about that.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 2: "Hamilton" is
one of the most talked about
and best loved musicals,
with shows on Broadway,
in London, and
around the country.
We wanted something
to make the show more
accessible for our
fans, so we wanted
to develop an app to
meet the needs of fans
as we started to
expand the brand.
We turned to POSSE, a New
York-based development firm
to help us develop
the Hamilton App.
Hamilton's floater app launched
in the app store and the Play
store three months after we
wrote our first line of code,
and we accomplished a ton.
Fans can enter a daily lottery
for a shot at $10 tickets,
buy merchandise through
an e-commerce experience,
take selfie photos
with the HamCam
and get daily news and updates.
MORGAN HALLMON: So very cool.
"Hamilton" is doing
exceptionally well on Broadway,
and it's pretty exciting
that they've built their app
on our infrastructure.
So it's completely built
on Serverless+Events.
It's got a number of
pieces of functionality.
They've got a lottery, and we're
going to talk a little bit more
about that later.
They got karaoke, trivia,
the HamCam, the selfie app,
and you can buy merchandise
from within the app as well.
So let's talk about the lottery.
So for those of you who
aren't familiar, the lottery--
you know Hamilton is
extraordinarily popular--
the lottery is an opportunity to
not pay the entry price, which
I believe is around $200--
but the reality is that
these things sell out,
so it's probably more
like $800 or $1,000--
but instead pay $10
to enter a lottery
and win a chance at tickets.
These are great tickets, I
think maybe 40 or so per show.
You sign up for the lottery
two days beforehand.
A day beforehand,
the drawing happens,
and you're either
select as a winner,
or you're told to enter the
lottery on a subsequent day.
And it's really interesting.
I love making
developer's lives better,
and I love making
you more productive,
but I also love, and I hate
to use the trite line--
in fact, I won't
use the trite line,
we're making the
world a better place--
but we're making the
world a better place,
in the sense that the creators
of Hamilton, with this lottery,
have allowed a whole new
demographic to actually access
Hamilton.
And it's interesting
because they're
all about flipping
models on their head.
The whole play itself is about--
it's a majority minority cast
portraying the life and times
of Alexander Hamilton.
And this lottery,
as I said, kind of
does the same thing for the
demographics of the audiences.
So how they're doing that--
so a user says, I want to
be part of the lottery.
Enter me.
That request then gets
written to Realtime Database,
which the backing store for
all of the Hamilton app.
It then triggers
a Cloud function,
which first goes
through Firebase Auth
to say that this is
a legitimate request.
That function then
registers the fact
that the user has chosen to
enter the particular lottery.
There's is a Cron job that
then operates down here
on a daily basis, triggering a
Cloud function that says who's
won on that particular day.
It selects the
winners, writes it back
into the realtime
database, and also
notifies the lucky seat
that these people have won,
print their tickets,
and the users
are told of their winning
status or to enter
the lottery the next day.
Really interesting feature.
Next feature-- the
HamCam, the selfie app.
So this is a pretty
simple feature,
but again, it's
completely Serverless,
completely Even-driven.
Users basically take a photo,
take a selfie in the app.
It then writes directly
to Cloud Storage.
This is actually a lot like
our theoretical example
that we went through,
mediated by Firebase Auth
just to make sure that this
is a legitimate request.
That then kicks off
a Cloud Function,
which crops and
resizes the image, then
writes that image URL back
to the realtime database
so that the user now sees their
wonderful selfie in the app.
And POSSE told us
that we made it
so easy for them with
the realtime database,
with Cloud Functions,
with Cloud Storage,
to build this feature
that, instead of operating
infrastructure, they could spend
much more time on just making
it fun, making it interesting,
and adding effects
like this to the app.
And then finally, last example
I'll show you from "Hamilton"
is the merchandising,
just buying merchandise
in the store.
So the user says, I
want to buy something.
That then kicks off two
different Cloud called
functions.
The first contact's
the Magento API,
which is an API for managing
e-commerce stores, things
like skew management pricing,
inventory management, all
done via Cloud Functions.
The next function then contacts
Stripe to make payments.
And this is a really
interesting application,
kind of a perfect
application, of Serverless,
in a sense, in that Stripe
doesn't trust mobile clients,
doesn't trust desktop
clients, to make transactions,
so it requires you
to have a private API
key that sits on a server.
So if you're a very
large site that
does tons and tons of
transactions per day,
maybe this is a non-issue.
But if you're an app like
Hamilton, where most of it's
about consuming content
and not really about buying
merchandise, then having
that infrastructure,
operating that infrastructure,
is quite a burden.
Cloud Functions allows
you to do that server key
without operating any
infrastructure whatsoever, so
a perfect application
for Serverless.
All right, so those are
just a couple examples
of what customers are doing
with Serverless, with Events,
to build very
sophisticated systems.
And now, I want to
show you something
that we can build very simply
using Serverless and Events.
So we're going to come back to
that example I showed earlier,
the Gallery app.
So we have a gallery.
It is backed by Cloud Firestore
that just went beta today.
Hopefully you all saw that.
It's an infinitely
scalable NoSQL database.
And what we're going to do is
we're going to upload photo.
It's going to hit Twilio.
We're then going to save that
down to storage into profiles.
We're then going to index
the data, basically take
the name that was entered
and the image URL,
put that into Cloud Firestore,
which will update our gallery.
And then that'll kick off
another function that then
analyzes the image,
pulls it out,
and extracts the visual
information via the Vision API,
writes it back into
Cloud Firestore-- sorry,
my pointer is dying--
and then updates the
gallery in real time.
And so with that, let's
switch to the demo, please.
All right so here's
our Gallery app.
And you can see I've, in
the interest of making
it easy to understand
what's going on,
I have both the name of the
person who's uploaded something
and the tags on it.
So we can search here.
It's a visual search engine.
So Connor put a dog in,
so we'll see that image.
We can search on things in
the image content itself,
like sky, mountain--
oops, if I could spell--
lake.
So you see we have a visual
search engine right here.
I'm giving Google Search
a run for its money.
Funny enough, this actually
doesn't look any different
from the original
version of Google.
So anyway, let's now add
an image to this gallery.
So I'm going to upload--
I'm going to walk
you through what's
going on behind the scenes--
an image, actually,
of my daughter.
So upload that.
Oops.
OK.
Let's see.
Hopefully connectivity
is good enough here
that that goes through.
And so I'm going
to show you-- one,
it's completely Serverless.
So I get Firestore
running right here.
That's our backing store.
I've got a number of functions.
So this is the SMS function
that talks to Twilio.
This is the function that then
writes the data into storage.
This is the function that
takes that data and storage
and extracts the tags rates,
writes it into Firestore.
And this is the function that
adds vision tags to our app.
I'm going to just show
you very quickly how
that flows through our system.
All right, so you can see
the very first function.
So sent-- OK, yep.
Name is Edie.
That's my daughter's name.
And the image was sent there.
Next step, let's see
if that completed.
This is saving it
down to storage.
Yep, success.
Next step, writing to Firestore.
Wow, a lot of stuff there.
OK, success.
Wrote it there.
And then final step is actually
running the Vision API.
And we can see all the
tags that come through,
so person, facial, smile,
child, girl, emotion, sitting,
standing, fun, laughter, all
added as tags to our image.
And now, if I look--
oh wow, I've got two copies
there of my daughter.
I hope that's not a demo bug,
but rather the fact that I
uploaded it twice.
Who knows.
So now I can search on
that, search on girl.
Then it shows up as well.
So that's our app.
So can we switch back to the
presentation really quickly?
So now I'm going to do
something potentially risky--
audience participation.
Now, it's your turn.
So text an image with a
name all in the same text.
I could be a picture of you.
It could be a
picture of your kid.
I put mine up there.
Your dog or anything--
it could be a flower,
but text me an image.
As I said, this is
a little dangerous.
And put it in our gallery.
I'm trusting you.
OK, let's see what we have.
So sky-- do we have any new sky?
Oo, we've got a
lot of stuff now.
All right, we've got
some new images here.
All right, we've got tomatoes.
This is cool.
Oh, let's see.
Let's do child.
I imagine we'll-- look at that.
Look at all those kids.
Cute kids, and I don't know
why we have two of my daughter.
Not sure.
Let me just put in kid.
OK, now I put in kid.
Boy, how about that.
Wow, man.
All right, how about fun?
All right.
OK, kids are having fun.
Car-- look at that,
some cool images.
So I don't know if you
noticed, but as I said,
I trusted you folks.
But I didn't show
it in the code,
but I've also got Safe
Search running, and so Dan,
I made a mistake in
trusting you, apparently.
To be clear, I
tuned this actually
and decided to be very
conservative because I knew
someone would upload something.
So it's actually very
possible this is just
a picture of a family vacation,
and Dan has his shirt off,
very possible it's
totally innocuous.
Linus, same thing-- this one, I
had to clean the word here, so
not sure that's so innocuous.
But anyway, you
can see that we've
built a pretty
sophisticated system,
and I'm operating zero
infrastructure here.
It's all being done via
Serverless via Events.
Can we jump back to the
presentation please?
All right, and so with
that, I wanted to recap.
Serverless+Events increases
developer productivity.
You can build more
powerful systems
with less code, less
infrastructure, and less work.
It's simpler, it's
more efficient,
and it allows you to build
more extensible systems.
There are a ton of sources
available on GCP to trigger
our Serverless framework
Cloud Functions,
and we're adding
more all the time.
Customers are using it, and
they're building real systems.
They're building powerful
systems using Serverless+Events
and, frankly, you can too.
And so here are a few
other Serverless talks.
A couple of these have
actually already happened.
There are few tomorrow as well.
If you're really interested in
Serverless, please go to those.
And with that, that's it.
Again, thank you so much.
I really appreciate your
coming for this talk,
especially at the
end of the day.
Now go forth and
enjoy your evenings.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]